6 26 city wednesday morning seems like
talking about speeders has really
touched a nerve
we had to drive a new crazy email from
wendy the other day she talked about
getting
raced off the road by folks doing 85 in
a 40 mile an hour zone
other viewers chimed in like dan who
writes we need more police sitting on
side streets waiting for speeding cars
on main streets it's ridiculous
how crazy people drive cutting in and
out now wendy also had commented on
drivers with no headlights by saying
that her everyday driving habit is turn
on the ignition turn on the headlights
well today's viewer dan points out there
is an auto feature
on newer cars where the headlights will
automatically come on at dusk you don't
have to worry about it
dan thanks for the tip and thanks for
writing in we are passing on all the
viewer comments about speeders and cars
with no plates to the folks at metro
buckle up drive carefully and please put
down that phone something's driving me
crazy
email me traffic eight at eight news now
dot com